let me ask you
to put put on your wise sage hat and
give advice to young people
so if you're talking to somebody who's
in high school in college what advice
would you give them about their career
about
uh life in general how to live a life
they can be proud of
well i'd say
the world is your oyster i mean first
order of business you're not a victim i
don't care what color you are i don't
care you're male female you're gay
straight whatever the world is your
oyster
you are so privileged you sit here in
the united states of america a free
country a rich country everything is
possible for you believe me you can do
anything okay
uh secondly i would say
uh mastery
over
the medium in which we're embedded
is the key to the future
so get educated focus work hard you know
invest in your future by acquiring the
skills that you need to be able to
navigate the 21st century
i would say
the chinese are coming and i don't mean
anything against china i just mean to
say the world's a small place and it's
getting smaller
uh and uh
you know
you better get moving and you better get
moving quickly
i'd say
your identity your coloration your your
orientation your your your category uh
is not the most important thing about
you that
uh you know
so uh the the temptation to limit
yourself i mean i give this speech to my
my kids i say
um
i i quote james joyce
uh
he has a a passage in um
portrait of an artist as a young man
in which he says uh
do you know what ireland is
ireland is an old sow
that eats her pharaoh
this is
joyce
he says
uh stefan daedalus is the character that
he has in mind in this uh chronicle he
says
uh
your ethnic inheritance he's talking
about irish nationalism
are like nets holding you back
that your challenge is to learn how to
turn those nets into wings
and thereby to fly
okay flying into the open skies
of modern society
don't be your
grandfather don't be your father
don't wear your thing so heavily that it
keeps you from being open to everything
that's new in the world
wear it lightly
yes everybody comes from somewhere but
it doesn't have to be where you end up
uh so you're you're not your father
you're not your grandfather
you are this uh wonderfully blessed
uh human being in the middle of going
into the middle of the 21st century
um and uh
don't miss it
don't don't don't live blinkeredly
don't live small
live big
uh live big and uh wear
your history lightly
yeah
everybody's got a mother tongue
everybody's got a story everybody has a
people
but the world is a small place
i love that you're quoting
an irishman
one of the greatest writers of the 20th
century a profound one
um but an irishman nevertheless the the
uh the levels of humor within that
is not lost on me let me just mention
the great ralph ellison the
african-american writer invisible man is
his
masterpiece
uh embodied
this spirit okay we black americans we
do come from somewhere that come from
somewhere from slavery in america that's
our
ancestral heritage
but that's not
what we are skin and bone
these are
superficial things the spirit and if i
were a more religious person i could
give a whole
disposition about that but it's the
spirit it's that light that's inside
that's that's who we are and our
challenge is to live in the fullness of
it uh as opposed to this
blinkered thing where we don't look left
we don't look right we're just fitting
within this template that we inherit
that is a
travesty
you